FM one of the heavier ver does anyone
actually know what the head of chapter
is financial mathematics is generally
speaking well general is video
specifically for FM one
it's about earning income basically it's
about trying to get money and how much
okay and that's why you can kind of see
these headings sort of put things
together there are the ten exercises I'm
pretty sure and even though they're not
in order that I'm about to write them
they fit under these three beeping so
when we talk about income streams we
mean like primary ways that you can make
money how many ways you make money
someone give you some suggestions ways
that you can make money Joe okay when
you get jobs there may be three kinds of
jobs and therefore many different kinds
of income and someone give me an example
of wages kind of so say 70 pages wages
alright so wages and salary is in fact
the very first thing that we're going to
look at we need you to sell you a
different bucket we'll talk about how
they different controlling even though
in some contexts this honest about what
we're happy
how's Emily well other ways apart from
that gives Commission Commission it does
so if you recall Commission is where I'm
in a complex of twenty ten houses they
just recently saw one for $800,000
so the real estate it's gonna make a
piece of that yeah that's what
Commission is about there's lots of
different right any I'll take its you
know there's one other kind
what main category and it's why it's
slower usually okay now we will get to
interest and that's kind of a way is it
income trip actually sets a really good
answer however we'll get to a more
formal you do with investing yeah
so keep that in the back of your head
the thing that was thinking I had fair
enough it's quite rare
this piece work so piece work is I make
a set number of objects in the more
objects I make and sell they're more
money either
now closely related to that and
something which unlike these which
you've done within the Junior School
something you hadn't done with so much
is royalties
what our Welty's oh good so if you are
creative of some kind right you then
give your work over to like a record
label or publish or web and then the
more they sell the more of well yeah a
little bit of a slice you can they call
them royalty right so you can see what
these are kind of lumps together right
it's kind of like the more you sell the
more incentive there okay so these are
correspondingly if you want you can read
this too it's not essential but this is
what a what you're going to do today
this is what C and this is one e so like
I said they've been out of water and I
will tell you what is in between them
right now exhilarating that's been the
funky where you might use through a
supplementary or additional or on the
side really technical and we mean that
not just ways of like thirty real money
but sometimes little extra bits of money
comes to you in a variety of different
ways so as I did if we go without wages
or salary wait really
who knows what purely
yeah a ton a half-double time I'm
working on a long weekend those kinds of
things public holiday right so we've got
those kinds of things there are also
things called loadings so for instance
over summer I actually get paid more
when I'm on holidays that's it funny it
all adds up to the same thing but many
salary jobs will do this does anyone go
what would they do that you're working
less and giving less throughout the
years than your holidays you so that's
kind of the way it works so that it's
actually not so much it makes it it's
all about marketing right yeah we pay
you for your holidays actually they just
withholding pay from you throughout the
whole yard because of days so that's
where that country there are other kinds
of things where else could you get money
for if not from my just straight up
burning it to the end okay so a retainer
we actually will address her at an
address of we get to here okay this is
because if you happen to be in
unfortunate sales when you
let's go that's telling things you still
need to earn some money that you still
being employed so retainers will come in
here another example of 120 minutes
these like allowances so I don't know
how many of you said to thinking a lot
kind of thing you might get youth
allowance or study or if you move out of
home etc stuff at Center League and
anything like Family Tax Benefit that
you're getting money you don't land
early yet but it's still coming to you
and then the last one I had on my list
was where is the loss of innocence oh
yes right
so bonuses are things like hey you
worked really well how company did
fantastic witness you so therefore you
sort of get a little bit extra at the
end tends to be Christmas as an
incentive like this to where College ooh
better
all right no lost category but where
it's not very fun and you have to figure
out money coming out we think about here
all of the cost to come like real quiet
we call them deductions
they often get deducted out of the money
you earn and you don't get a choice
about it does it even know any kinds of
common deductions that currently pay no
food by an English okay fantastic
so superannuation is probably legal one
that's like that gets taken out and it
just gets walked away and you can't
access it even though it's yours
yeah tax okay now tax is an interesting
one taxes actually a brake pad that is
in the general course tax is a big deal
because she's loads of maths in tax
that's hard to understand which is what
makes me so sad you don't do maths
because they could they would never
understand in case one wants to
understand an all-in-one solution
because tax it's only big thing we
actually would want leave it we will
deal with as mascara many other things
that you might consider if they need to
go my people who want to go to a church
thing you probably rack up a bit of debt
as you know it's called start of an age
exdeath is often what it is call higher
education something Compensation Scheme
I think go look it up the idea is that
you can go there you know TAFE or
whatever it is cost free and you don't
have to pay any interest on that loan
until you start earning with right and
then the more money you earn the more
they take out because they're like oh
you're using your degree in your
qualification so therefore it makes
sense that you can pay off some of your
education because that make sense so
these again they get taken out and if
you don't get a choice about alright so
there's a common deductions one last
year when you have all these costs -
they didn't take it out you want to be
able to manage the money that you have
where so really this is a really great
which is budget right like now you have
all this money what do you do with it
and how do you ensure that you have
enough for your play ends off of buying
this or that so there's a sort of a
thumbnail sketch of the whole body